[Música]
hoy vamos directo a nueva york con
nuestra corresponsal mamen sala y es que
los y las futbolistas de la selección de
eeuu lograron un histórico acuerdo por
el cual se les pagará de manera
equitativa así concluye una demanda que
interpusieron los jugadores para exigir
igualdad además porque ellas han tenido
más victorias y más premios
internacionales que los futbolistas de
su país vamos entonces a nueva york
mamen bienvenida y cuéntanos por qué es
histórica esta decisión
si se trata de un acuerdo histórico que
logra la igualdad salarial entre los
jugadores hombres y las jugadoras
mujeres dentro del fútbol profesional
aquí en los eeuu ha sido un pacto al que
han llegado la federación de fútbol
estadounidense y las diferentes
selecciones de jugadores y jugadoras
nacionales de este país el pacto de
momento se mantendrá hasta el 2028
además incluye otros aspectos como que
por ejemplo se reparta en los ingresos
de la parte comercial o que haya el
mismo tipo de compensación económica en
las ligas incluyendo por ejemplo la copa
mundial de la fifa además también se
ofrecerá ayuda económica y ayuda a apoyo
para aquellas mujeres que tengan que
dejar a sus hijos durante una
convocatoria de las elecciones
nacionales y también se ofrecerá un plan
de retiro un plan de jubilación a todo
esto megan rapinoe ganadora dos veces de
la copa mundial ha dicho que esta
situación le parece surrealista que
llevan mucho tiempo peleando por estos
derechos pero también se ha sentido muy
agradecida porque esta victoria esta
justicia que se ha hecho es algo que van
a poder aprovechar las generaciones que
llegan ahora y cuéntanos cómo comenzó
este reclamo
si la primera denuncia se hace ante la
comisión de oportunidades de igualdad de
empleo en el 2016 cinco jugadoras de
fútbol profesional denuncian que están
siendo salarialmente marginadas que
están cobrando menos que los hombres y
eso no es justo en esa primera disputa
participó de hecho megan rapinoe tres
años más tarde en el 2019 28 jugadoras
de la selección nacional de fútbol que
denunciaron a la federación precisamente
por lo mismo por una marginación
salarial por ser mujeres lo hicieron
ante una corte federal de los ángeles en
california bien el pasado 22 de febrero
esta primera disputa en la que participo
megan rapinoe se resolvió y salieron
ellas vencedoras recibieron una
indemnización de 24 millones de dólares
y el hecho que estamos viendo hoy que
haya una igualdad salarial entre hombres
y mujeres que juegan al fútbol en este
país es uno de los primeros países en
hacerlo algo que realmente es histórico
y además pues muy justificado dicen
algunos expertos porque tenemos que
recordar que aquí el equipo de fútbol
y cuatro copas mundiales algo de lo que
no puede presumir por ejemplo el equipo
masculino de fútbol gracias por toda
esta información y seguimos con más
directo américa